how many turkeys
God love you nine and a half million
turkeys I tell you what
it's like some of the countries I've
been doing
anyway
thank you
really it's something else all right all
right all right I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report it is the day before
turkey day Wednesday November 23rd 2022
and that was the elderly man pretending
to be president doing his little turkey
pardoning and I think his nine and a
half million turkey joke it was either
racist or was just the General State of
Mind melting confusion that he usually
is in and then of course he wanders off
there at the end as always we are live
streaming on Rumble YouTube And blazetv
subscribe if you have not yet and uh
although this appears to be live right
now at 11 o'clock as always uh we were
pre-taping this because I let my guys go
home for turkey day and I would assume
that at the moment I am deep my hand is
deep in a turkey people right at this
very second uh I just want to catch up
on a little bit of the stuff that went
on over the last couple days you know we
didn't get too far into this Nancy
pillow OC
vacating her
post as a head of the Democrats in the
house so we're going to hit that and
then I want to talk about something with
Don Lemon for just a second then Reuben
report Community Q a trying to keep it
light before the holidays and there we
go so first let's just start with Don uh
because Don remember Don who nobody was
watching was exposed to be a nonsensical
partisan hack over and over and over
again as Tucker cross and calls him Don
Lemon uh he was very upset that no
Jeopardy contestants knew katanji Brown
Jackson's name katanji Brown Jackson of
course is the new Supreme Court Justice
she is the one who could not Define what
a woman is but on Jeopardy nobody knew
who she was clue that raised eyebrows it
was the moment that followed this moment
she's the first black woman on the
Supreme Court and the first Justice to
have been a federal public defender
that's Justice Jackson katanji Brown
Jackson
though when you go into that point when
you go on Jeopardy you just confirmed
okay listen if you're standing outside I
think Caitlyn's right if you're standing
outside of a mall or whatever and people
may not know when they do the man on the
street fan yes but when you're
smart enough to be a contestant on
Jeopardy you got to know about current
events
maybe not any successful in history
making once yeah
yeah all right
well you know every now and again one is
going to get by even a great contestant
on Jeopardy you were just waiting I know
what you were thinking that entire time
he's about to call them all racist
that's what I kept thinking too he
actually did not call them racist but he
just can't believe it that actually and
maybe it would explain the election
results a lot of people just don't care
about a lot of this stuff even the
Wizards who are contestants on Jeopardy
uh but of course the other big thing in
the last couple of days that we we did
not give it enough attention here
because we were traveling and it's been
a little nutty Nancy Pelosi alcoholic
Nancy Pelosi with her crazy eyebrows and
her dentures that are falling out and
her husband who maybe was having a gay
affair with a homeless guy something
like that she announced she's stepping
down and with great confidence in our
caucus I will not seek re-election to
Democratic Leadership in the next
Congress
for me the hours come for a new
generation to lead the Democratic caucus
that I so deeply respect and I'm
grateful that so many are ready and
willing to shoulder this awesome
responsibility
it's been super interesting seeing the
reaction to this thing obviously anyone
on the right you know people have just
had it with Pelosi and you know that
moment I think her worst moment there's
a lot of bad moments and a lot of you
know calling half the country racists
and all that stuff but when Trump was
giving the State of the Union a couple
years ago and then immediately after she
just tore up the speech and you know
these are the people that are constantly
telling us about Civility and decency
and the rest of it uh there was
obviously much more that happened during
that speech that moment that I always
talk about when Trump's talking about
all-time lowest Black and Latino
unemployment and the Congressional Black
Caucus sits there like this and you know
several house members I think including
AOC didn't even show up to that speech
so I think Pelosi uh you know even
though I'm going to show you a clip in
just a sec the media is still fawning
all over her for what she accomplished
or I guess purported to accomplish
whether we like it or not
um you know I think she'll mostly be
remembered for being hyper partisan and
once again just delivering more power to
the government and less power to you
here's Mika Brzezinski on the televised
mental institution known as MSNBC on how
we should just honor that great woman
Nancy Pelosi no it's the end of an era
and an incredible one and um I mean
whether you're a Republican or a
Democrat it's sort of hard not to be in
awe of what she has accomplished unless
you're in a cult uh coming up we'll get
much more reaction
I mean I just don't know what did she
accomplish like she accomplished getting
rid of trump she accomplished impeaching
Trump wasting a ton of time with the
January 6th earrings uh getting us into
a recession you know voting endlessly
for more and more money to Ukraine like
trying to give the devil's new here what
did she really really accomplish I'm not
sure I mean I guess they got their
inflation reduction Act passed
um didn't produce inflation but like you
know I guess she got more diversity and
Equity probably into the system of the
federal government but she's telling us
we're in a culture okay but the
important thing is now that old white
woman Nancy Pelosi is going down at
least on the bench what do they have
what's the most important thing is it
qualifications is it competency is it
your ability to do good work and that
you have the right ideas in your head
and you're going to put four things that
are going to free people or is it just
skin color
recent people dislike on the on the
right Nazi Pelosi is because she
outlasted them she's off because she was
affected and take a look at the people
that look like they're going to be the
next caucus leaders for the Democrats
can we pull them up
guess what you see there you see
diversity you see youth you see a woman
you see I mean it just you know it's a
it's a wonderful thing to see and it's
something that we can't ever take for
granted because just a little over 100
years ago women couldn't vote yeah and
now this woman showed us that she could
lead you see diversity you see youth
first of no one there look that young
the woman in the middle is they're
leading young uh you see a woman all
right congratulations we just had a
woman again it does not nobody cares
what everyone wants right now are just
competent leaders I get it that she's a
progressive and she's just going to go
down with the ship of equity and faux
diversity but how about diversity of
thought wouldn't that be nice if you had
a democrat in there who wasn't a
complete brainwash leftist wouldn't that
be something but here we have I couldn't
even tell what was going on there one of
the guys was black maybe he was sort of
black and then he had a guy that maybe
was kind of Latino and a woman with gray
hair who I guess was young I don't know
what's going on here God these people
are bananas let's get to the Ruby report
Community Q a uh Nathan says what is
your favorite food of the Thanksgiving
feast well Thanksgiving is the one
holiday that we host we host all of
David's family and uh we they are a
whole bunch of great chefs and David's a
great chef and I I've gotten pretty good
myself if I do say so uh I will be
smoking the turkey and the Big Green Egg
so there will definitely be some
pictures posted in the in the locals
community of that my favorite food David
makes an incredible uh what is it it's a
uh squash soup a Chipotle pepper squash
soup which is really really excellent
but like if you get a good piece of
smoked turkey I smoked the turkey last
year you get a good piece of smoked
turkey right amount of cranberry sauce
just the right amount of gravy you get
some good mashed potatoes on there some
stuffing
it's really good Tony says now that Bob
chapek is out at Disney and Bob Iger is
back in they replaced Bob for Bob do you
think Donald Duck will get his job back
or is he still wandering the streets of
Orlando
in case you're wondering what that
question's about here's a little
throwback to my Orlando show with
Governor DeSantis
[Music]
billion dollars
[Applause]
41 billion dollars in about a month
Donald Duck
is wandering the streets of Orlando
sucking dick for a hot lunch
hilarious huh will Donald Duck get his
job back I don't know I don't know maybe
could they just give Donald Duck pants I
mean I think that was part of the
problem Donald Duck for you know what is
it 50 60. how many years is Donald Duck
what give me the year that they came up
with Donald Duck it's got to be 80 years
ago at this point something like that
Donald Duck's never had pants you know
what I mean so you've got this duck and
he's got the rich uncle and the cousins
and the whole thing and he's not wearing
pants it makes no sense
1934 that's when Donald Duck debuted wow
that that is something 88 years for
Donald Duck no pants wild Grace says
over the weekend I heard just how much
we are spending in Ukraine why are we
doing this with no oversight look I've
discussed this several times with Rand
Paul if you didn't see my interview last
week that we did on location in DC check
it out
um this is how the government works and
until enough Republicans get some balls
and I think maybe now that they've got
the house some balls are starting to
descend we will never have any answers
on any of this stuff it feels like a
giant slush fund a giant money
laundering funnel how could we do this
how can we give billions and billions
and billions of dollars to another
country we have no idea what their
processes are around this money Rand
Paul tried to get something passed to
get some basic receipts and basically
everybody in the house pretty much
laughed at him it's like we have so many
problems here we also don't have money
do you understand that we borrow money
from the Chinese to then give to Ukraine
and then pay
uh penalties on that money that we've
borrowed in the first place it's not
like we have extra money what is it that
our politicians somehow think they are
getting by giving giving your money that
they have to borrow on
to the Ukraine it's it's really really
wild I don't have any great hope that
we'll get uh any receipts on this stuff
but it's one of the reasons that people
hate government oh we have hurricanes
here we have mass destruction here we
have acts of God whatever it might be we
have Urban blight go to Detroit whatever
do we put enough money into that if
we're just saying that these coffers are
endless we never put enough money into
that but we can somehow give money so
that Ukraine you know zelenski can do
whatever he wants Gifford says did you
have fun on Gutfeld here's a little clip
from Gutfeld on Friday you are near
retirement age
you think that that joke would be near
retirement age
wow
[Applause]
really no it was necessary yeah I
thought I deserve it see what's
happening to you guys you're New Yorkers
so you're bitching and moaning about
nothing
[Laughter]
that is so true we're in Florida now you
don't have to complain about every
little thing
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I go to the green room before I'm like
what a wonderful day Hard Rock Hotel Fox
people everyone's happy Greg I have
Diaries
[Applause]
okay but what keep that New York up
north you hear me so that clip is sort
of an example of what I like doing on
the show you know the way these shows
work uh well the way most late night
shows work I should say would be that
they're going to send the guests the
topic most of them don't do Hot Topics
but they just plan it all out right so
when Jimmy Fallon or Stephen Colbert one
of these other clowns when they're
asking the celebrity a question it's
just all pre-arranged with the public
relations manager and there's very
little spontaneous spontaneity or
anything sort of really interesting
happening in the moment there when we do
the gut felt show what happens is that
morning they send the topics to to my
assistant she sends them over to me and
I glance at them and I try to get like
one kind of funny idea or something
silly or every now and again I'll just
go kind of straight up factual if it
warrants it uh but I'm trying to get one
of those in my head but what the moments
that I really like are the moments like
that when it starts getting loose and
breaking up and you can use the crowd a
little bit and one thing you know I can
give Greg a lot of credit on a lot of
fronts and I'm so proud of him and happy
for him that he is the king of late
night as I predicted on the first ever
episode of the Gutfeld show I said that
he would be within six months I think it
only took him three months
um but he he loves it if you throw it
back in his face you can make fun of him
you can hit him he likes it when it's
loose and that to me is like the really
fun part of it not not all TV is that
fun some of them are just kind of very
straight some of them are very like you
know you just get that one moment to say
one thing the good fellow show is is a
ton of fun Greg is really a great guy
Tim says how is 2022 treated you so far
uh well as we are in the stretch run of
2022 uh this has truly been one of if
not the best year of my life truly I
mean first off I have I have two young
Sons like that's pretty great right we
got Justin and we got Luke two months
later the day and life has uh has
changed I'm definitely a little more
tired than I normally would be and and
doing more laundry because people are
spitting up on me and all sorts of stuff
but like it's really been beautiful and
wonderful and and I feel very blessed or
I can I think I can speak for both of us
that we both feel very blessed for that
also you know look living here in
Florida living in a place that is so in
line with my values and being an
integral part of fighting for that
whether it was doing the show on
Election night at DeSantis headquarters
or uh just being part of all of the
things that are happening here and you
can just feel it's just good here and it
feels good and that's so in contrast to
much of what 2021 was for me which was
being you know locked up and you know
fighting with morons on the street about
masks and you know my dog wanted to
sniff somebody's butt and them freaking
out because the dogs were getting too
close and it was just uh it was just a
lot of nonsense it's been a really great
year the the show this is by far our
biggest year ever every month continues
to be our best month ever I think my my
co-workers and colleagues are happy and
we're just gonna keep building and and
keep in the State of Florida free and
you know building out our own
communities and seeing what happens uh
Karina says now that Republicans have
the house do you think Biden will just
get out his pen and executive order
everything look this is one of the
biggest problems that we have in
government you guys get the Civics 101
stuff the president is not supposed to
sign he's supposed to sign things into
law but he's not supposed to write the
law one of the things that we've done is
we've outsourced so much of the
legislative power that Congress and the
Senate are supposed to have because
they're supposed to be writing up the
laws and then the president looks at him
he either signs them or he doesn't but
we've outsourced so much of that to the
president himself that you can do this
by executive order and then of course
what happens the next president comes in
right after that and because it wasn't
passed by Congress in the first place
you don't need a legislative action to
get rid of it so if one guy comes in
signs something the next guy comes in
signs the reverse the next guy comes in
signs something in the middle and then
the next guy does something completely
different it's a huge problem it's what
we tried to escape right by leaving the
British Empire because we did not want
to be controlled by by a king in that
case and in many ways we seem to want
the president to be the king so I think
yeah Biden will probably try to do a bit
more by executive action but that really
was why it was so important even though
it obviously was not the Red Wave and
that the Republicans didn't get the
Senate and you know a couple of these up
in the air gubernatorial seats like
Michigan I would say in Arizona in
particular Pennsylvania I wasn't as
bullish on but they didn't go red but by
getting the house you can stop some of
the nonsense will Biden just do it by
pen and will people put up with it
probably to some degree Velda says has
the money in the jar been awarded to
some lucky California that's ready to
jump ship I don't have any extra cash to
put in the jar right now but we will
have to make some decision on that
somewhat soon I'd like to do it we got
to announce that before Christmas so
that it's a nice Christmas gift for
somebody but yes we will get someone out
you know I had changed it over the year
I was going to say oh no we'll just take
a Democrat and move them out of Florida
but that's going to be a little more
complex to do so we will save someone
I don't know if it have I officially
said that it has to be from Cali I guess
it has to be from yeah it has to be from
Cali I'm just willing to save someone at
this point it could be Michigan New York
whatever no it's someone from Cali we're
just going to give you a bunch of cash
get your ass out here I'll take you out
to dinner too and live freely uh
Veronica
says how much of your decision to move
to Florida was about being close to
family and raising your boys around
their cousins so what's really nice is
that my sister and my brother-in-law
they live in Miami they have three kids
my sister actually gave birth the week
after Justin our first so we've got a
whole bunch of kids here my brother is
three kids he's up up in New York my
parents split time between New York and
Florida so it was a lot easier to be
around the family thing here than it was
in Cali and Cali we had no family really
on either side as you know with distant
cousins and things out there
um but that definitely was a part of it
and at the last moment look you well you
guys know I wasn't leaving because uh
for taxes or anything else I was leaving
for all the the crazy reasons of covid
and the lockdowns and Newsome and I Was
An Enemy of the State and we tried with
the recall and everything else but then
once we started looking at the options
and Nashville and Dallas were it was
basically Nashville Dallas and then
somewhere in Florida not necessarily
Miami likely Miami but somewhere in
Florida and I looked at some houses in
Nashville we looked around Dallas a
little bit obviously I do some stuff
with the Blaze and I love Glenn and all
those guys and then Florida when it had
the added bonus of being closer to
family particularly my sister and her
kids and that the fact that my parents
are are down here you know as I've
mentioned their their place on Sanibel
basically was destroyed but hopefully
we'll we'll rebuild and uh and it yeah
especially when you're having kids to
then be around family so they can have
cousins and aunts and uncles and
grandmas and grandpas it's all good uh
lck did Reuben report send Joe a
birthday card oh that's right it was Joe
Biden's 80th birthday on Sunday don't
ask him though I don't think he knows
exactly how old he is we should have
sent him a birthday card we should have
sent him one of those Donald Trump cards
you know those Donald Trump birthday
cards he opened up YMCA is playing
Donald Trump wishes you happy birthday
maybe I got one of those on my birthday
I'm just saying
um no we did not we did not send him a
card uh Nate says hi Dave I've been
thinking about the election and
wondering to what extent the abortion
issue may have cost a few Republicans
their wins outside of my religious
conservative bubble I personally know
many libertarian slash conservative
leaning people who just aren't on board
with an abortion ban and I knew they are
not alone do you think this one issue
might remain a major problem for
Republicans this is a great question and
I tried to address it a bunch before the
election because on one hand the women
particularly women particularly young
women that are pro-choice
meaning again meaning for abortion
they are rabidly so and they do put it
often in many times as the Apex at that
type to the top of the hierarchy right
of what they will vote for and if they
felt that their lives were going to be
directly threatened by potentially
States outlawing outright abortion or
maybe with some exceptions maybe not et
cetera et cetera then it does push a
whole bunch of them to vote now the
counter to that is there are many people
sounds like uh you yourself that come
from a religious background that do not
want abortion at all and they may have
been fired up so it's a little the
question really is which base got fired
up more was it the people who were
thrilled that Roe v Wade got struck down
and that it was going back to the States
and that was going to encourage them to
vote for more Republicans because
Republicans in this case Trump by
appointing these Supreme Court Justices
came through on a promise or was it the
people who suddenly felt that their uh
that their life or their views were
threatened I tend to think it was those
guys right because then that gives you
the impetus to oh boy I better get back
out there and vote for a Gretchen
Whitmer or vote for a Gavin Newsom
because I really really think they're
coming for me
again this is where and I know I bring
everything back to Florida but this is
where a state like Florida has done it
so right 15 weeks that's three and a
half months that's the cutoff point with
some exceptions and that is within the
framework that I've heard DeSantis talk
about many times which is he has his own
personal religious beliefs he's Catholic
his own Catholic beliefs lead him to
being pro-life but he understands that
his Catholic beliefs do not dictate the
public policy of the State of Florida so
Florida did a compromise a 15-week
compromise which nobody is fully happy
with right because everyone everyone
sort of admits 15 weeks is arbitrary you
know it's arbitrary to some degree
nobody's through the pro-life people are
not thrilled they're not getting what
they want the pro choice people are not
fully thrilled because they wanted to go
longer so that's what compromise is
we're doing it right here in Florida and
of course we're doing it right we're
doing compromise in a in a free Red
State as opposed to who are the real
radicals well it's the eight and
half-month abortion people in California
but it's a good question and I tend to
think the pro-choice people did get
riled up a little bit more than the
pro-life people but whether it really
affected the elections is hard to say
Amy Says after all the results from this
last election and people still voting
Democrat how do we take down the liberal
media people are saying the Republicans
had no plan but how would anyone know
look this gets to almost everything I
talk about it's like if we've got all
the right ideas right like why do I not
have to scream at you every day when we
do the show I can calmly tell you what I
think you know any day some nonsensical
breaking news can happen and I can sit
here and go through it with you and we
can we can discuss it and go back and
forth and I can look at your comments
and you maybe disagree with me maybe you
agree with me on this or that
maybe one day you're in full agreement
with me the next day you're disagreeing
with everything but we can we can all
kind of agree that like you know I think
you probably think this I've thought
most of this stuff through I'm trying to
be a somewhat honest Arbiter of what's
going on in the news uh the left because
they have so much of the institutional
power and the cultural power and the
media power and the big tech power at
least for now it's changing because of
eon
um they've confused a whole bunch of
people
how is it like I really I would love to
find somebody and and maybe if you're
watching you can find me somebody like
someone an influential person in
Michigan that really felt boy Gretchen
Whitmer did a great job during lockdowns
and she really deserves another term as
Governor now clearly there were
literally hundreds of thousands into
millions of people that felt that right
I mean that's how it is she won so
Gretchen Whitmer who in my estimation as
a free American and someone that cares
about the Constitution and your ability
to do what you want and live your life
as you see fit she was sort of the worst
of the worst but she won
Gavin Newsom the worst of the worst but
he won
that's just reality Kathy hochel but she
won so a certain amount of people are
going to be brainwashed and that's why I
I will always focus on that let's say 10
that can move and this is a great well
I'll get to this in the next question
because Caroline is saying uh what do
you predict will happen for the next
seven months between DeSantis and Trump
well first off look we know Trump has
announced so there's going to be a lot
of energy going towards the Trump thing
there's going to be a lot of focus on
the trumping does Trump get back on
Twitter what is going to happen with
that are they going to re-censor him
like does he then get back on Facebook
or Instagram or whatever it might be
like there's a whole bunch to figure out
there DeSantis we just don't know my gut
feeling and I have no insight into this
any I have no personal insight into this
uh other than just what my gut feeling
is which is he's gonna just keep doing
what he's supposed to do wouldn't that
be the best thing you know Trump
announced really really early think
about it it's two years till the
election so Trump has this 2 Clear
Window to create chaos potentially bring
on board better people than he brought
on last time because a lot of people
thought that that was deficiency to keep
fighting the machine to keep talking
about drowning you know draining the
swamp to go out and do the tours but
it's very very early and can you sustain
that the entire way through I think he's
thinking this is just going to be like
this this push all the way through that
no one will really challenge him and
he'll just kind of cake walk his way
through it
um to me if I was DeSantis and again I
have no insight into this other than
what I'm telling you if I was to say
this I would just do what I think is
right I would just keep doing what I've
been doing well here in Florida and then
if you're going to make the choice to
run well then maybe in say six months
from now when it's still a year and a
half away from you know the election
like or you're doing even a little bit
closer to the Iowa caucus thing then you
announce you're running and you just say
look I'm not going to get into the
personal stuff here's my record here's
what I've done for the State of Florida
here's how I would like to translate
that at a national level and that's what
I'm going to do so hopefully they're
there won't be too much fighting between
them over the next six months or seven
months as you put it I don't think there
will be because I just don't see
DeSantis I see no reason for DeSantis to
make a move at this point
cine says I'm disturbed by the recent
talk about removing the DNR from ballots
including with your in uh including your
talk with Tim Poole which was great I
know that not every Republican is great
but the odds of them being less
tyrannical are very good what do you
think so what she's referring to there
is that in on Tim Poole's podcast which
I did last week we were discussing
voting and how you know they always put
the D and the r next to the candidate's
name or the L for the libertarian party
whatever it might be and Tim's argument
was that they should just remove that
because it in essence it gives too much
power to the parties
I think you can actually argue it either
way the argument that I was making in in
that conversation was that generally
speaking it's what you just said right
there Republicans at the moment are just
better who locked you down who forced
the mandates who wanted to kick your kid
out of school who wants higher taxes who
wants to import racism who wants to chop
kids genitals off I could continue
it's the Democrats so by putting the
party affiliation on that you know many
many people you go into these ballots
and this happens to me sometimes too
even though I'm usually pretty well
versed in what the what the actual
issues are because sometimes you're
voting on issues you're voting on do you
want to put tax dollars to this that the
other thing you know there's all these
different things that you're voting on
on top of you may just not know every
candidate like you go into a
presidential we don't have to do even a
midterm one but you know you go into a
voting booth uh to vote for president
and then you have all sorts of other
things going on there not only you might
have state senators and governors uh but
there are judges on there a whole bunch
of other things and you just don't know
all of the things right you got to live
your life and you just don't know all
the things even if you are pretty well
read and you pay attention to a lot of
this stuff so my argument with Tim
basically was I think you'll leave it
there because for the people that
roughly know what they think and
hopefully a decent amount of us do it's
like if I if I don't know and I've done
this I I think I did it on one or two uh
one or two was it trying to remember
like exactly what it was there might
have been one or two people here that I
did not know on the ballot that I was
just like oh republican I'm gonna do it
and I voted Republican all the way
because my general feeling was yeah if
you don't know well then my beliefs the
stuff that I talk about here is more in
line with what the Republican party is
right now and that could flip I suspect
it will sometime in my life and then
probably flip back uh Jeff says last
question Jeff says what are some of your
professional and personal goals for 2023
well on the professional side
look this as I as I've said a couple
times lately this has been our biggest
year ever we've never put any money into
advertising but the show continues to
grow and grow and grow we just did this
great trip to to DC so now we know we
have Studios that we can use down there
I just want to keep being a piece of the
puzzle of Sanity you know as some of the
censorship stuff hopefully breaks then
what that does is if if you think of the
the people that are that are confused
about the ideas right now many of them
are confused about the ideas because
they can't hear the right ideas well now
Elon comes in and he starts banging away
at that Iceberg right chipping it off
and then people now are kind of floating
in the water and you're able to grab
them and show them the better ideas I
hope we can draw more people in to the
better ideas and and continue to have
good important conversations and
interview the people that I that I'm
interested in and find new people that
are blazing new trails and building new
things you know the the locals Rumble
situation is just on the up and up and
it's and it's going and it's blazing and
I'm going to keep trying to help and
deal with the the speech policies around
that and a whole bunch more uh and that
we continue to just grow everything
we're doing maybe do some more things on
location we've been discussing maybe
doing some live studio audience things
so so a whole bunch on that front and I
would say on the personal front
um it's really just continuing to try to
be a good dad I suppose like how much
more uh would there be than that you
know just making sure that uh you know
that I'm the type of guy when I open up
the door in the morning and I see the
kids they give me a smile and uh you
know I'll give them some food in
exchange for that maybe change a diaper
and uh and then
just keep building upon that I think I
think that would be good enough but on
on that note I am very thankful not only
for the the success that you guys have
afforded me and some of the personal
things that have happened this year uh
but I'm I'm thankful for the guys in
this room and my entire team I'm
thankful for for everyone that
participates at whatever level you do uh
in watching this show I'm particularly
thankful for everyone that plays along
in the reubenreport.locals.com community
and I hope on that note that you will
enjoy the turkey the cranberry sauce the
stuffing the mashed potatoes the wine
the dessert the apple pie whatever else
it is the family
the friends all that good stuff take a
day be thankful and uh we'll see you
soon my fellow Americans this coming
Thursday we'll celebrate a holiday that
belongs uniquely to our nation
Thanksgiving Day
millions of us will travel from all
parts of the country to gather in family
homes observing the holiday according to
long-standing tradition turkey with all
the fixings pumpkin pie laughter the
warmth of family love and yes a moment
of prayer to give thanks
yet at the same time many Among Us will
be less fortunate
and just as Thanksgiving day has always
been an occasion for counting our
blessings so too it's always been a time
for making life better among our fellow
Americans in churches and synagogues
across the country for example food will
be collected in the next few days for
distribution to the needy or on
Thanksgiving Day itself and with this
Spirit of Thanksgiving in mind I thought
I'd speak with you for a moment this
afternoon about the goodness of the
American people
and our willingness to give each other a
helping hand
the spirit of volunteerism is deeply
ingrained in us as a nation maybe it has
something to do with our history as a
frontier land
those early Americans who gave us
Thanksgiving Day itself had to help each
other in order to survive joining
together to plant crops build houses and
raise Barns and perhaps they discovered
them helping others their own lives were
enriched
in our own day a poll showed most
Americans believe that no matter how big
government gets and no matter how many
services it provides it can never take
the place of volunteers
in other words we Americans understand
that there are no substitutes for gifts
of service given from the heart
in our recent history there was a time
not long ago when this Spirit seemed
endangered when philanthropy and
personal involvement were giving way to
bureaucratic plans and federal programs
so when our Administration took office
we made it one of our main aims to
encourage private sector initiatives
to reinvigorate the American tradition
of volunteerism and I have to admit our
success in this area is one of the
accomplishments of which I'm most proud
for in the past few years we've
witnessed an unprecedented outpouring of
the volunteer Spirit a tremendous
reassertion of Goodwill and
neighborliness
but is good to reflect
that here in America perhaps more than
any other Nation on Earth we have a
tradition of giving of neighbor helping
neighbor that makes life better for tens
of thousands every day
and for this too on Thanksgiving Day
let us give thanks
until next week thanks for listening God
bless you